[Música]
el principio de incertidumbre de
heisenberg es una idea de la física
cuántica adoptada por la cultura popular
que establece que nunca se pueden
determinar simultáneamente la posición y
velocidad exactas de un objeto y sirve
de metáfora para todo desde la crítica
literaria hasta los comentarios
deportivos la incertidumbre se explica
como resultado de la medición que la
acción de medir la posición de un objeto
cambia su velocidad o viceversa la
verdadera causa es mucho más profunda y
sorprendente el principio de
incertidumbre existe porque en el
universo todo se comporta como partícula
y como onda al mismo tiempo
en mecánica cuántica la posición y
velocidad exactas no significan nada
para entenderlo tenemos que pensar Qué
significa comportarse como partícula o
como onda las partículas existen en un
único lugar en cualquier instante de
tiempo podemos representarlo en un
gráfico que muestre la probabilidad de
encontrar el objeto en un lugar
determinado que parecerá una Punta 100%
en una posición específica y cero
cualquier otra posición las ondas son
alteraciones que se propagan en el
espacio como las ondas en la superficie
de un lago podemos identificar las
características propias de su patrón y
su longitud de onda que es la distancia
entre dos crestas o dos picos negativos
consecutivos pero no podemos asignarle
una sola posición hay una buena
probabilidad de que estén muchos sitios
diferentes para la física cuántica la
longitud de onda es esencial ya que está
asociada a su momento la masa por la
velocidad un objeto a gran velocidad
presenta un mayor momento que
corresponde a una longitud de onda muy
corta un objeto pesado tiene mucho
momento incluso a poca velocidad e
implica una longitud de onda muy corta
por eso no notamos la onda de los
objetos
si se lanza una pelota de béisbol la
longitud de onda es una mil millonésima
de una billonésima de billonésima parte
de un metro cosas pequeñas como los
átomos o los electrones pueden tener una
longitud de onda suficientemente grande
como para hacer medidas en experimentos
si tenemos una onda pura podemos medir
su longitud y su momento pero no tiene
posición podemos determinar la posición
de una partícula pero al no tener
longitud de onda no podemos medir su
momento para conseguir una partícula con
su posición y momento mezclamos los dos
dibujos para crear un gráfico que tenga
ondas pero solo en un área reducida lo
logramos al combinar ondas con
diferentes longitudes de onda lo que
significa darle a nuestro objeto
cuántico alguna posibilidad de tener un
momento diferente
cuando hay dos ondas hay sitios donde
las crestas se alinean y crean una onda
más grande y otros donde las crestas de
una coinciden con los valles de la otra
como resultado se crean áreas donde
vemos ondas separadas por áreas que no
presentan ninguna con una tercera onda
las áreas que no presentan ondas se
agrandan añadimos una cuarta y el área
sigue creciendo mientras que las áreas
con ondas se estrechan si seguimos
agregando ondas creamos un grupo de
ondas con una longitud de onda en una
pequeña región esto es un objeto
cuántico con dualidad onda partícula
pero para lograrlo debemos perder
certidumbre sobre su posición y momento
su posición no se limita a un solo punto
se la puede encontrar en un Rango a
cierta distancia del centro del grupo de
ondas el grupo de ondas se creó al
agregar ondas Entonces es muy probable
encontrarla con el momento
correspondiente a cualquiera de esas
ondas la posición y su momento son ahora
indeterminados y las incertidumbres
están relacionadas para reducir la
incertidumbre de la posición haciendo el
paquete de ondas cada vez más pequeño se
deben Añadir ondas lo que crea mayor
incertidumbre del momento para
determinar mejor el momento se necesita
un grupo de ondas más grande ese es el
principio de incertidumbre de heisenberg
formulado por primera vez en 1927 por el
físico alemán werner heisenberg esta
incertidumbre no se debe a buenas o
malas mediciones sino que es la
consecuencia Inevitable de la dualidad
partícula onda
el principio de incertidumbre no es solo
un límite práctico de la medición es un
límite de las propiedades que un objeto
puede tener inherente a la estructura
básica del universo mismo
sumérjase en el alucinante mundo de la
mecánica cuántica y vea si puede
intentar resolver uno de los
experimentos mentales de más triste fama
del campo con este video
[Música]